so that is exactly how nextgs works and
is different from a reactions build and
that is why next chairs are super fast
super easy and super performing hey
everyone welcome back my name is mehul
and in this video we'll be discussing
what exactly next chairs is but more
importantly how it exactly works because
you would have seen a lot of videos on
react nexus what is the difference but
let's just go ahead and with the help of
this whiteboard get a little bit into
the technical details of how in the
architectural sense next year's works
compared to reactors okay so before we
get into next year's let's actually
understand how reactions works in order
to appreciate what next years does so
what reactions does is that on a
production website this is a server this
is a client and this server could very
well be just a cdn right it need not to
be a server like ec2 or anything it
could be just a cdn as well cdn is just
a dumb server which just knows how to
present files right it does not know how
to compute and stuff i mean it knows
telesat and degree but you cannot really
run scripts and everything cdns are
optimized for file delivery not for
compute so this cdn delivers this client
a single file on the handshake right
index.html now this index.html actually
contains inside a source code it
contains something known as bundle.js
now this file could be named pretty much
anything but i think the default name
for react is bundle.js and this
bundle.js actually contains a lot of
javascript code which contains the react
runtime which contains what the page
should look like in terms of jsx and the
components
how the routing should work how
your pages should be structured should
be layout and everything so basically
this index.html right here
is pretty much blank
so it's
pretty much a blank document which only
contains this bundle.js as a bootstrap
point now why do we do this this is
required because react is fundamentally
a javascript framework right it cannot
run without javascript even to construct
the layout when you do a return return
h1
instead of jsx
this actually gets compiled down to
react.createelement and that's in tax
rate or some modern syntax with js6
right but
this technically is still javascript
it's not html in order to do that it has
to deliver a javascript file to the
client and the client has to execute
this javascript first so it has to
execute this javascript first in order
to understand what the page should look
like this is how very simply react.js
works server right here has very minimal
role in terms of speeding up your
application right the server right here
can only do so much it can just increase
or decrease rather the time to first
byte that is how soon this server starts
responding and you can pretty much max
it out by using a cdn here instead of a
server right you don't want to use an
ec2 instance or a digital ocean droplet
here if you're using a static website
using react.cs but rather you want a cdn
here which is cdn which is placed around
the world for it to speed up the
delivery and the delivering your static
files next chase on the other hand
however is a bit interesting and why is
that that is because some of the
features of next year's actually require
you to run a live server now this server
in fact could be serverless but it needs
a node.js process right so it needs a
node.js process and the fact if you're
using it with a provider like warsaw
which has a first class support for next
chase you can actually put a cdn in
between as well this is the important
part with nexus alongside with the
server side rendering as well but we'll
discuss that so let's assume you are
hosting a website on whatsapp right now
you can do it on aws as well using
something known as aws serverless nexjs
there's a whole full-blown architecture
in serverless how you can use aws for
that but warsaw is very very simple
compared to this setup okay so what is
happening here is this is the client and
remember what we discussed with
reactions is that your bundle.js
comes from the server and gets executed
and the page is displayed right so what
some people thought well
what about if we try to execute this
react instead of on client on the server
and send the initial generated document
to the client it seems like a nice idea
right i mean on first thought you might
understand that this this seems like a
valid idea that you just generate the
html on the server and send it to the
client but the problem here is that this
html needs a bit of revalidation that
means in react you write event handlers
and functions and you access window and
you do a use effect which runs after the
component is mounted and all of that is
not available on the server right it is
too expensive to just run a puppeter a
headless browser and render it and you
know do that stuff so what people do is
they actually wrote a renderer server
side renderer for react which is known
as react dom slash server right so this
is actually a package which you can also
use to natively export the react dom
into a static html string which then you
can rehydrate by rehydrating what i mean
is that you just magically
attach all the eventlessness again to
the static html blob which you sent and
that's done but again there are multiple
problems here it's not as simple as just
doing this stuff and that is where next
js comes in that is where this next
year's framework comes in because it
abstracts away all of these details of
rehydration and server side trending and
everything from you and on top of it
because it is running on a server it can
actually give you additional superpowers
which are not present with just a simple
static reactions button so what
nextgears does as a first job is that it
renders the same page on server right so
it renders the same page on server which
you're seeing in a next year's in a
react js application once it does that
it creates an html blob out of that
right so this is an html document which
is up and ready for the person to just
open in the browser and if you don't
know this html is in orders of magnitude
faster than javascript so if you have a
document which just shows some html
document and if you have a javascript
document which constructs that from the
scratch then you're gonna see that
browsers are very very very optimized to
display the html part very quickly
compared to executing the javascript
because javascript is a programming
language right it needs to boot up the
whole v8 runtime environment in order to
pass the language syntax and do so much
stuff html on the other hand is a markup
language and browsers have really
optimized themselves to actually
construct layouts very quickly so html
is very fast compared to javascript
based dom rendering right so that is why
next js is super fast compared to
reactions for javascript now this
difference probably does not matter a
lot if you have very small or simple
applications but if you are approaching
a size where this difference becomes
kind of like you know 50 to 100
milliseconds then it can impact the user
experience even 100 to 200 as well right
so and this happens right this happens a
lot of times if even if you just have a
library like moment.js for example for
date parsing which is a very common job
right if you do it on the server side
and create an html out of that that is
much much faster compared to doing a
moment.js render on the client side and
then displaying the formatted date all
right so the first thing next yes does
very well is that it renders the html on
the server side and generates this blob
of html data which we have the next
smart thing which it does at least if
you're hosting it on whatsapp or
yourself or you know you're using a cdn
is that this can store the statically
generated page on the cdn right so what
the cdn is like we discussed briefly
it's a content delivery network but in
simple words it's just a dumb server
right so it's a dumb server which
does not usually execute a lot of code
right so this is a dumb server it is
just meant to serve files to the user
that is it that's all it does and the
second thing cdn does is that it is
pretty much you know spread across the
world so if this is earth then you're
gonna see that companies like aws or
cloudflare or even versacell i think
versus uses aws anyway so these
companies have a lot of cdns in multiple
countries right which are ready to serve
any sort of file closest to the user so
this cdn can deliver files super quickly
right the fact that you don't have to
render this react on server is super
critical because node.js is not friendly
with cpu right node.js is a slow
language for cpu bound tasks that means
whenever your server side rendering it
chances are that it is going to be a
slower time to first byte right because
your
server would actually
need to compute the html that is why
with frameworks like nexus which
supports server side rendering the best
mix is actually using server side
generation plus revalidation what is
this this is exactly what we talked
about which is a bit of a cheating in
the sense that you do generate the page
with server-side rendering but you put
it on the cdn the cdn delivers it to
multiple clients in a very fast way and
then maybe you are regenerating this
page in the background every five
seconds or every two minutes or every
three minutes or whatever you want to do
right so even if your server is a bit
slower in generating the page completely
from scratch your clients do not face
this problem because they have been
served by the cdn which is super fast
right so this is a super interesting
architecture and it can suit a lot of
applications from code down for example
we use next year's server site
generation a lot to news articles to
blog posts to generic websites as well
which don't require a very critical
real-time data thing and even if you do
require that then you can always
separate your view layer from your you
know real-time data layer so this client
could probably connect to a websocket
here which is hosted on aws let's say
and then this websocket can retrieve
real-time data but the main document
which serves the page itself can very
well be hosted on a cdn right and it can
be done in react therefore this client
receives the page super fast it's seo
friendly there is performance there is
pretty much anything you can think about
now remember i told you that whatsapp
does need a server here running or maybe
serverless and the reason for that is
because of the server side regeneration
server side revalidation basically
because what you can say to yourself on
the server side itself is that hey let
me just go ahead and regenerate this
page at most one time every five seconds
so the moment you do that
versa automatically runs some sort of
script or whatever internal architecture
they have but the cdn flashes out
whenever there's a new copy of the page
available right so whenever the server
says that hey there's a new copy
available for this then the cdn says
okay i'm just going to stop serving the
older copy and start serving the newer
copy to the clients right so for this
process you need a server whatsapp needs
a server and again you don't really
manage this if you're hosting it on
versailles if you're hosting in this on
aws then of course you have to manage
that stuff a bit but yeah i mean that's
that's pretty interesting so that was a
bit about what next.js is and how it
works on an architectural basis
hopefully if you were new to nextgs or
react you were able to get a grasp of
the idea what next chase is and how it
works on the server side of course there
are more components to next shares just
compared to just what we discussed but
maybe we can take up that in probably
some other video so that is pretty much
it for this video if you liked it make
sure you like and subscribe thank you so
much for watching and i'm gonna see you
in the next one really soon
[Music]
[Music]
you